- This week, we've asked our audience
to tell us their favorite
Kellyoke performances
from last season.
So Vanessa in our house
seats has a special request.
What do you want to hear and why?
- Hi Kelly.
(Vanessa chuckles)
Today I'm requesting the song
"Good as Hell" by Lizzo.
- Yes.
- I just love this song so much.
It's because it's about female
empowerment, loving yourself.
And I know it's helped me
through a whole lot of hard times
and also this phenomenal wonderful singer
just happens to be my baby sister.
- What?
- Lizzo
- Are you serious?
(audience clapping)
- I remember the first time
that I heard her do the
demo for "Good as Hell"
and I had never heard
her sing or rap like that
before in my life and I just knew
it was going to change our lives forever.
And I was right, it did.
- Oh my gosh. I'm freaking out right now.
Wait, so when did you know?
Cause I know she also plays instruments.
So was she in the band kind of girl first?
And then all of a sudden
she just started singing
and rapping out of nowhere.
- Oh yeah, she was always
in little rap groups.
She was always making her own
version of Destiny's child.
Yes. She was a band geek
as well, playing the flute.
And then one day she just,
this beautiful voice came out of her
and it was the most amazing thing to see.
- Oh my gosh, you have
an awesome little sister.
She is so fun to watch.
She's so talented.
I tried to do it justice, but I love her
and I don't feel like I did,
but I love that you're requesting it.
Thank you so much, Vanessa.
It's lovely to meet you.
(audience clapping)
- Nice to meet you too. Thank you.
- All right and don't worry,
tell her we all envisioned
we were in Destiny's child at some point.